today the Matt wall show the media have
gone to insane lengths in their smear
campaign against conservatives in the
wake of the Colorado shooting this
includes the most egregious case of
defamation I've ever seen and I happen
to be the target of it also the left
have gone all in with their defenses of
child drag shows and drag queen story
hours but why are they so desperate to
keep exposing children to this kind of
debauchery I think I know why and I'll
explain and woke white journalists are
virtue signaling in Qatar and it isn't
going exactly well for them plus a
Quantum physicist tries to prove that
quote the universe is queer all of that
and more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
Roe versus Wade has been overturned and
this battle is now finally leaving DC
and going to the Grassroots so no group
in America is better positioned than 40
Days for Life uh in this moment in
history with about 1 million one million
Volunteers in a thousand cities four
days for life holds peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities they have a
larger president presence in blue states
with California being the largest state
some former abortion facility directors
say these vigils can cause the abortion
no show rate to go as high as 75 which
is detrimental of course to their
abortion business these law abiding
vigils have closed many abortion
businesses in America and nearly half of
those closed abortion facilities were in
Liberal cities where abortion will
remain legal including closures in San
Francisco Chicago and Seattle 40 Days
for life is effectively changing hearts
and Minds in the Grassroots to end
abortion you can check out their
locations podcasts and free magazine at
40daysforlife.com and remember this
fight is far from over we still have so
much more to do so if you want more
information and join the fight on 40
Days for Life go to 40daysforlife.com
well if you thought that the media's
exploitation of the gay club shooting in
Colorado Springs had reached its most
depraved lengths yesterday when we first
discussed it on this show then you
haven't been paying very close attention
uh because whenever you think they have
sunk as low as they can sink there's
always a still deeper depth to reach and
they will reach it by God they will
reach it we still have been given no
official information about the shooter's
motives but that hasn't slowed them down
at all the contrary the lack of
information only frees the media up to
disseminate even more wild and unhinged
propaganda the media is in a race
against the clock always when something
like this happens because I need to get
all the talking points they can out into
circulation before the relevant facts
are actually known that way whenever
they are known if they ever are uh it
won't matter because the LIE has already
as the saying goes traveled halfway
around the world as we talked about
yesterday the ambulance chasing vultures
immediately identified
a number of villains in the shooting
people to blame for the shooting the
shooter himself barely even makes the
list of people to blame certainly they
won't blame the court system that
allowed this man to roam free after he
was arrested for serious felonies last
year including three counts of
first-degree kidnapping instead they've
singled out primarily Tucker Carlson
Donald Trump because of course uh Libs
of tick tock and then me I have been
blamed by name in many major media
Outlets but it was the daily coasts
yesterday afternoon that won the
defamation competition
they publish this headline this is what
they published
Matt Walsh only upset quote more people
weren't killed at Club Q Twitter takes
highlight GOP hypocrisy
notice the quotes they put the phrase
more people weren't killed in quotes in
a clear and deliberate attempt to give
the impression that I had said that
myself
of course I said no such thing and never
would because unlike the staff at the
Daily Coast I am not a psychopath
but if you read the article it says it
begins quote it wasn't enough that five
people died and 25 were injured when an
lgbtq Club was the target of a mass
shooting on Saturday night in Colorado
Springs Colorado right-wing commentator
Matt Walsh kept spreading hate about a
community already suffering largely
because of a concentrated effort from
Republicans to translate misguided fear
about the trans Community into political
power
quote leftists are using a mass shooting
to try and blackmail us into accepting
the castration and sexualization of
children Walsh tweeted these people are
just beyond evil I have never felt more
motivated to oppose everything they
stand for with every fiber of my being
despicable scumbags
now yeah I did tweet that okay and the
Daily Coast is certainly not doing
anything to disprove my thesis that
these people are despicable scum but
it's not until later in the article
buried four paragraphs down that they
reveal the source of the once more
people killed quote it wasn't from me
but from a trans activist an all-around
loathsome Dirtbag named Alejandro
carabaio
but of course most people don't read the
article especially when it's published
by The Daily Coast and how can you blame
them all they will see is the headline
which is intended to give the impression
that I said what the trans activist
actually said
interesting to note here that the writer
of this article is a woman named Lauren
Sue s-u-e
her last name weld May well be a glance
into her own future our team at the
daily wire has already sent an email to
the Daily Coast demanding a retraction
and apology by the way just deleting it
is not going to be enough retract it and
apologize to me personally
we've also referred it to our general
counsel you know I understand that the
left is used to playing the game by a
different set of rules
but um there are limits and they have
crossed a line here not just crossed it
I mean they are several miles over the
line at this point
and we're not going to tolerate that
there will be a penalty
we'll have I'll have more to say about
that in the coming days
um
but there's something else notable
Happening Here aside from the egregious
smear campaign against me personally the
left has also identified this as an
opportunity
to launch a full-fledged campaign to
defend and normalize child drag shows
and drag queen story hours
now there's no indication still that the
shooting had anything to do with any of
that and even if it did I mean even if
it's an if the shooter was in part upset
about drag queen drag queens grooming
children
that obviously wouldn't mean that it's
actually good for drag queens to groom
children
be that as it may the mainstream news
channels yesterday filled their Airwaves
with over-the-top superlatives for men
who enjoy cross-dressing in front of
children for example here was journalist
in quotes and he quotes for that for
sure Brandy zadrovsny on NBC here's what
she said and we've also seen and and
there was a lot of conversation about
this um The Denver Post covered it about
drag shows being targeted what is going
on with that yeah because they targeted
drag shows a lot and in part because
um drag time Story Hour where a drag
queen would come it was a ubiquitous in
libraries all over the country had a
drag queen would come read a story it
was fun the kids loved it and then also
some sort of friendly friendly drag
shows it would be on a Sunday brunch you
could bring the kids they'd see a show
and the far-right conservatives left on
this and they put it together with
frankly the Q Anon narrative that's been
out and it was they were out to get
their children the demonization
dehumanization and moral Panic around
children in our community somehow being
threatened by lgbtq teachers Librarians
performers that is the thread that's
going through and when you demonize
someone to that extent and you make them
feel like an existential threat to you
and your children it's no wonder again
that we get this kind of violence
drag queen Story Hour was ubiquitous she
claimed she wants to make drag queen
Story Hour seem like a tried and true
American tradition something you could
trace back to the founders in which
far-right extremists suddenly decided to
have a problem with because of Q Anon
they're actually Q Anon conspiracy
theorists this has been the tactic NBC's
Ben Collins took a similar line here's
what he said
how significant are those two dates yeah
and also hours before what they called
an all-ages Drag Brunch which is
probably the number one target of these
uh anti-lgbtq
um events recently like for example the
proud boys will go and protest any Drag
Brunch any um any drag Story Hour
anything that a child might go to meet a
drag queen not you know just to show
them that they're human beings and
people they talk they go there and they
they read Dr Seuss there they read uh
regular books uh but it's read by a drag
queen and they you know they have
breakfast uh it is not some hypersexual
event but that's what it's viewed as on
the far right and these spaces have
become dangerous places of real life
information Warfare this proud boy
showing up on one side sometimes people
like local antifa members show up on the
other side as a as a way to it it
becomes a place where kids aren't safe
not because of the event itself but
because of this culture War that's been
propped up on top of it and that's not
something that should happen this is not
something you know these people should
be able to live their lives without fear
of being murdered literally uh but right
now that's the sort of climate that's
been created by uh anti-lgbtq
protesters and frankly bigots
frankly bigots
the kids go to the drag show or drag
Story Hour to meet drag queens he says
it doesn't see anything creepy about
that
of course he fails to mention that the
kids don't go there okay they don't they
don't like get in the car and drive
there themselves they are taken there
no child is asking to spend an afternoon
meeting drag queens Mommy Daddy can we
go see a drag queen today kids aren't
doing that if the child's being raised
properly he doesn't even know what a
drag queen is
my kids have never asked me that because
uh number one I'm I'm raising my
children to be normal children and
number two they have no idea what a drag
queen is they've never been exposed to
it because they're kids
these concepts are introduced by adults
and the adults take the child to quote
meet the drag queen and why do they meet
them well Ben says to make them the drag
queens feel like human beings
at least he has the order right the drag
shows a drag story hours they exist even
according to its Defenders for the sake
of the drag queens themselves
the cross-dressing men want to do this
in front of children and so children are
offered up for the purpose of satiating
this strange desire somehow the way to
make them feel human to make them feel
alive
to make them feel like people is to let
them cross-dress in front of kids not
just to let them cross-dress but to let
them cross-dress in front of kids
these drag queens today according to Ben
they don't feel human unless they're
allowed to wear women's clothing in
front of kids
now Ben is lying of course when he says
that they just read Dr Seuss obviously
the books they read are almost always
LGBT propaganda because that's the point
of the event
the combination of children drag queens
as has a this is something that has a
clear and recent history it doesn't go
back into ancient history it's recent
in fact Chris Ruffo another culprit in
the mass shooting according to the media
had a report a few weeks ago about the
ideological origins of drag queen Story
Hour as he notes quote enterprising
queer theorists use the
commercialization of drag and the
Goodwill associated with the gay and
lesbian Rights Movement as a means of
transforming drag performances into
family-friendly events that could
transmit a simplified version of queer
Theory to Children the key figure in
this transition was a genderqueer
college professor and drag queen named
Harris cornstein
stage name Little Miss hotness who
hosted some of the original readings in
public libraries and sits on the board
of the drag queen Story Hour non-profit
organization founded by Michelle T in
2015 to promote children's drag
performances kornstein also co-wrote the
manifesto for the movement called drag
pedagogy the playful practice of queer
imagination in early childhood
they proposed The Writers Do drag
pedagogy as a new teaching method
designed to stimulate the quote queer
imagination teaching kids quote how to
live queerly
though drag queen Story Hour events are
often built as family-friendly cornstein
and Keenan the writers explain that this
is a form of code quote here dqsh strike
with Story Hour is family friendly in
the sense of family as an old school
queer code to identify and connect with
other queers on the street
that is the goal is not to reinforce the
biological family but to facilitate the
child's transition into the ideological
family okay so the drag queens who came
up with this stuff said that this is
family friendly in the sense of queer
code when they say family in the sense
of meeting other queers on the street
that's according to them
that's the kind of family-friendly
environment
the environment where you meet other
queers on the street
that's the environment that they're
putting kids in
that's the sort of family they're trying
to connect kids to
so we see the drag queen Story Hour and
family friendly drag shows quote unquote
have two purposes
one from the drag queens perspective is
to satisfy their fetish for
cross-dressing in front of children
the other on a more macro level is to
indoctrinate children into queer Theory
to put it simply
the point of drag queen's Story Hour and
the child the the supposed
family-friendly drag shows is to turn
your children queer that is the goal
and whenever you say that what I just
said right there is let me clip by me
any matters hello everybody on Twitter
um
the people who invented it stated
explicitly that that is the point to
help children live clearly that's their
quote
and the thing about the left is that
what they believe and what they do
all of it is so horrifying so perverse
so degraded that if you just quote them
then you somehow sound like the crazy
one if you quote what they are saying it
may it sounds crazy just to say it out
loud because it's so horrifying
yet it's true
and this is the reason the left cares so
much about this and they defend it so
vigorously because according to the left
think about this
according to the left
the drag queen child combination has
become dangerous they say it's a
lightning rod for violent backlash
right that's what they say and it's
greatly exaggerated of course mostly
it's invented out of whole cloth
actually but
but even by their version of events
if it's causing this much chaos and
violence
why do you insist on continuing to do it
if according to you it's like putting
people's lives at risk
if if the effort to have men
cross-dressed in front of children is
putting people's lives at risk why are
you still doing it is it that important
to you
now as always they try to flip the
burden around on us
they demand that we explained why we
object to children being exposed to drag
queens and we can't explain it and we
have and we will continue to because
it's very easy to explain drag is
inherently sexual and ideological it is
burlesque and it's not appropriate to
bring your child to a burlesque show
you disgusting freaks
but why should we be the only ones
explaining instead of asking why we
oppose it so much we should ask why they
support it so much that according to
them they will keep doing it at the risk
of life and limb
why is it so important to you to
cross-dress in front of children
why is it so important why do you need
to do it why
is it worth the cost that you claim
you're paying for it
why do you have to do this why can't you
just not do it
how is that would that be a fight if it
is really causing all this chaos again
that's your version I don't uh uh agree
with that you're exaggerating but
according to you that's what you're
saying
is it why
nearly all children lived and grew up in
this country for almost two centuries
without ever being involved and are
exposed to a drag show and they were not
any worse off for it this is not filling
some sort of need that children had
so why do you act like it's some sort of
desperate need now
why can't you just not do it is it that
hard to not cross-dress in front of kids
is the compulsion that overwhelming
well we know the answer even if you
won't say it
this is part of your childhood
indoctrination campaign it's an
important part
and you must indoctrinate them young you
realize because the older they get they
get the more they will see you
for what you are and your agenda for
what it is
and that's what this is really about
let's get to our five headlines
living a healthy lifestyle is not
especially easy especially when you're
on the road as much as I am I need easy
manageable routines which is why I'm a
huge fan of balance of nature balance of
nature fruits and veggies are the best
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day their products are 100 Whole
Food balance of nature uses a cold
vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption balance of nature sent
a bunch of their products down to the
studio for my team to try and we all
love them when you're disciplined enough
to take care of your health you reap all
kinds of benefits more energy less
fatigue better focus consuming the right
balances of fruits and vegetables every
day is an important First Step so go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code Walsh
for 35 off your first order as a
preferred customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Walsh for
35 off your first preferred order
you know one positive I have noticed to
amid this propaganda campaign from the
left
um in the wake of the uh of the uh of
the tragedy in Colorado
is that
you know they're getting more and more
desperate because they realize that
their tactics actually aren't working
so the left they rely on we know that
they can't defend or explain their
positions you know we know we know that
and as we said when it comes to drag
queen Story Hour and like why do you
need to combine kids and drag queens why
is that so important to you why can't
you just stop
um they won't say out loud they can't
answer the question they like there's no
answer they can give to that that
wouldn't sound completely disgusting and
so instead they just try to deflect and
make us put us on the defense
but
you know
so so because they can't defend it what
they rely on
is censorship obviously and also
self-censorship so two kinds of
censorship there's the you know the the
censorship on their part the active kind
of censorship where they're stopping us
from from communicating our points of
view shutting us down then there's also
self-censorship where they berate us so
much and lie into famous so much and
threaten so much that we just stop we
ourselves stop saying whatever it is
they don't want us to say and for a long
time both of these they had a lot of
success in both areas
but in recent weeks months you know
um
in recent times in both areas
they're starting to lose
when it comes to censorship well they've
lost Twitter
um it would seem anyway that they've
that they've lost Twitter it certainly
is not the censorship mechanism we
already know it's not the censorship
mechanism that it used to be
now there's a lot that remains to be
seen but but uh Elon Musk is already
invited about not just Donald Trump but
a whole bunch of people on the right
back to the platform so they don't have
that tool anymore to the extent that
they used to and even self-censorship
you know they're starting to realize
that they can go around they can blame
us for mass shootings they can call us
this and that and it just doesn't
it just rolls off our back nothing you
people say means anything to us it
doesn't mean anything
because we know you're full of garbage
and everything you say is a lie and so
it just doesn't matter
you can it you could say whatever you
want well you can't say whatever you
want if you get into defamation then
we're going to sue your asses but uh
beyond that if you want to you know
whatever whatever insinuations insults
whatever labels you want to put just
doesn't have any effect
and they're noticing that because in the
past you know the way this would have
gone is that uh there's a terrible mass
shooting
they erroneously blame us and say that
our anti-groomer stance has caused this
and then they shot it from the rooftops
and then a lot of people on the right
say well we better not talk about this
anymore even though what they're saying
is totally bogus where you know it's
it's they're mad at us and let's stop
talking about it
but that's not the reaction on the right
anymore
it's not that's how the new right
operates the new right says yeah it's
you can say whatever you want you can go
on CNN every single day and scream about
it doesn't matter
you have no control over us you have no
power
and that makes them desperate and Afraid
frantic
and when it comes to this they are just
they they don't know what to do
because they're saying to themselves
wait a second we're using a mass
shooting against you we're using a mass
shooting against you we're using a mass
shooting as a political pawn and and
that's not enough to make you all
fall silent
in the past that would always work these
days it doesn't
and they're desperate speaking of
desperate on The View yesterday I just
want to play this for you it's not
exactly a lead headline but uh they were
talking about all this yesterday and and
uh
Jesus you know it's one thing to
defame Libs of tick tock or me or
Christopher or Donald Trump or you know
one of The Usual Suspects that's one
thing
um of course infinitely more outrageous
and offensive is when they try to drag
Jesus Christ into this which is what
they did on The View listen to this
they were in a place that accepts them
for who they were and someone came to
that place
I don't know that they hide behind
religion because I said this on this
show once before Jesus would be the
Grand Marshal at the pride parade I
don't mean about gay people I mean in
every argument we have but here's the
weaponized religion but it's wrong if
you're so afraid why are you going over
there yeah if they scare you so much
leave them alone when stuff scares me I
leave it alone if I don't want to be
bothered I don't go there see that's the
problem you don't want to just have your
feelings you want everybody else to join
you and you know what you can you can
scream you can cuss you can do all the
things that you say but you know what
gay people are here they're not going
anywhere there is nothing you can do
you know you can yell and scream but you
know as as the Lord as everybody was
talking about you know made in God's
image yep made in God's image there are
no but except for there's none of that
no keep that in mind when you're trying
to figure out where you stand as a human
being let alone a Christian we'll be
right back
it's I mean it's just amazing because
she says you can't just have your
feelings you need everyone else to join
you what that that's that's the left to
a t that's the perfect uh way of
describing the left especially the LGBT
left and gender ideology you can't just
have your feelings you need everyone to
join you you can't just feel like the
opposite gender you need everyone else
to join you in affirming you in that
but what I really appreciate is that the
one chick at the beginning starts by
saying
um and I honestly don't know any of
their names except for Whoopi Goldberg
enjoy it so I know those two other two I
don't know the other however many it is
um the chick at the beginning says that
they're weaponizing religion they use
religion and then for the rest of the
segment all the other women on the panel
do what she just accused conservatives
of doing they start using religion to
weaponize it against their opponents so
they're like contradicting exactly what
she just said and what we hear from one
of them is that um
Jesus would have been the Grand Marshal
at the pride parade
would have been the Grand Marshal
well that's wrong on many levels but
let's talk about two of them
one is really basic here is that Jesus
would not be the Grand Marshal of any
parade that has pride in the title
because pride is identified in scripture
repeatedly and by Jesus himself
repeatedly as a sin
okay have pride is a sin now it's one
thing the English language sometimes
falls short when it comes to translating
biblical texts and so we have to we have
to kind of figure out what is meant by
Pride because you can have you could say
that I could say I'm proud of my
children I'm proud of my family uh you
could even have pride and
accomplishments
you know if you accomplish something
because I'm proud of doing that I'm
proud of the work that I did nothing
wrong with any of that
because you're taking pride in something
else right you're taking pride and
achievement something that was done
you're taking pride in in someone else a
family member you know that's just uh
which is another way of saying love it's
just you you love them
um
the kind of Pride that we're warned
about in scripture is this kind of
haughty vain
self-centered egotistical
I am the center of the universe kind of
pride which is exactly the sort of Pride
that the pride parade is designed to uh
communicate and convey and celebrate
It's All About Me hey that's what the
whole pride parade is right it's just
everyone look at me look at me
that's all it is
so it doesn't even matter the context
whatever the context if you're engaging
in that kind of Pride Jesus is not going
to celebrate it with you he's going to
have some Stern words for you about uh
turning from your sin
but then there is also the context it
takes to keep in mind here and and you
know because you brought it up right
they brought it up they brought up the
Bible they brought up Christianity
you brought it up
and so we must inform you that what
you're saying about Christian teaching
and about scripture is just incorrect
the Bible does in fact in both the Old
and New Testament in very explicit terms
um uh
uh lay out the homosexual act as a sin
you know in fact
any sexual act that happens outside of
the bonds of marriage is a sin according
to a Christian
sexual morality biblical sexual morality
and also according to the Bible
marriage between man and a woman
that's what it says
now you can now if you're on The View or
someone aligned with them you could say
well I don't care what the Bible says
all right but you but you're the one who
brought it up like you just brought it
up so they try to do both this is their
game
and in that clip you heard both on one
hand no one cares what the Bible says
don't use your religion and then on the
other hand and by the way I'll tell you
what your religion says about this
and the game is that if if you correct
them on what your religion says then
they can revert back to the first
talking point and says why are you
talking about religion you brought it up
so they can make whatever claim they
want about your religion and if you
correct them and say well actually
you're wrong it's not what our religion
teaches like can I as a member of my own
religion can I tell you I mean you're a
bunch of atheists secular Godless uh
humanists can I can I can I tell you as
a member of that religion would it no no
I'll speak for you they say
it's totally absurd all right
this is from euronews.com I don't think
I've ever read a headline from them it
says an American journalist has claimed
that he was detained on Monday after
trying to enter World the World Cup
stadium in Qatar where same-sex
relationships are outlawed while wearing
a rainbow shirt in support of the LGBT
community so this is Grant Wall is his
name and he put a picture up there very
proudly he's got the he's got the
rainbow flag and he says just now
security guard refusing to let me into
the stadium for USA whales you have to
change your shirt it's not allowed he
says uh he says that he was
um
taken away and that he was detained for
nearly a half hour but then he says that
they uh that they had later apologized
to him and let him into the let him into
the country so that's what he says
happen
and we're seeing stunts like this and
usually the stunt is is quickly
abandoned there have been various
including the USA team you know
originally they were talking about
rainbow Flags changing uniform and they
didn't really end up doing that but they
did have I think in their practice
facility they had the rainbow flags all
over the place so
we're getting this from these from uh
some of these Western people that are
showing up there
um
but you just see it's interesting how
quickly
the respect all culture stuff
goes out the window isn't it
I mean say what you want but
this is Qatar it's their country
it's a non-western non-white country
and now you've got white people white
westerners like Grant Wall showing up
and saying I don't respect your Customs
I don't respect your your beliefs I'm
going to do what I want in your country
I'm going to tell you how you should run
your country
your laws don't mean anything to me
because I'm the white western guy and
I'll I'll tell you I will influ I will
show up and be and be the uh and and be
the the Arbiter of morality
the source of morality
it is a it is a form of this kind of
moral colonialism
that you see from the West this
ideological colonialism
that you see almost uniquely these days
from the left
and yet in any other context these same
people would claim that they're all
about multiculturalism well you don't
care about multiculturalism if you're
not accepting a person's culture
including the parts of it you don't like
so if you're saying I'm a
multiculturalist I enjoy
multiculturalism
um I enjoy all cultures and I respect
all cultures except for the parts of
those cultures I don't personally prefer
and that don't line up with my values
well if that's the case then you don't
believe in multiculturalism and you
don't respect other cultures
it's kind of like saying I respect all
free speeches over the speech that I
don't like well then you don't respect
free speech
so it all goes out the window
immediately
and also I I do have to say and there
have been uh some you know Qatari
citizens who have uh
spoken out about this here's one for
example says as a Qatari I'm proud of
what happened I don't know when will the
westerners realize that their values
aren't Universal there are other
cultures with different values that
should be equally respected let's not
forget that the West is not the
spokesperson for Humanity now we talked
about this a little bit yesterday and um
you had the president of FIFA that was
saying well the West has a lot to
apologize for but he meant historically
he was taking about taking him back 3000
years and so he was doing the whole
white guilt routine going back 3000
years in all of our and all of our
dastardly sins
um that is absurd
but if we're talking about modern day
for talking about the West in in modern
times the West right now
I would agree that we just are not in a
position to morally lecture anyone I'm
afraid to say
we in the west are not in a position
so we can put ourselves in a pedestal
and say oh those look at those those
qataris and their disgusting laws they
have no respect for human decency
we're just not in a position to assume
the moral High Ground we don't have the
moral High Ground we surrendered it
in this country we did
it's very sad to say but it's true
like we talked about yesterday we live
in a country
uh in in in in modern times where we
execute
we've executed 60 million babies in the
womb
60 million
and if you believe that those are human
beings then you believe that in our
country we and I say we in the general
sense are responsible for arguably the
worst Mass Slaughter of the innocent
that's ever happened on the planet
and then to make matters worse we also
castrate sterilize our kids we don't
even have a a sense of you know what a
man or woman is anymore we're just
utterly completely confused
we celebrate evil and debauchery in its
most deranged forms that's what we do in
this country
and then we think that we're in a
position to go and
ideologically colonize the globe and
tell them they need to be more like us
well the problem is that the other
countries when we say that when we give
that pitch and we say you should be more
like us
well the members of the other country
they look at us
like freaks they look at us like a bunch
of confused weirdos they they look at us
and say well I don't want to be like you
why would I want to be like you
mean over in your country where you
think that men can get pregnant
I mean over your country where you're
sterilizing little boys to turn them
into girls
you are surgically and medically
altering little boys to make them girls
and you think we want to be like you
it's just it's not a convincing sales
pitch
I noticed this when I was over uh when
we were in Kenya and it was it was very
sad to see
that the people in Kenya they look at
America Now with uh really it's like a
it's almost like a paternalistic
pity
like a kind of there there you sad
confused children sort of thing
when they hear about what's happening
here and can you blame them
you saw in the film I asked one of them
you know would you ever want to move to
America and they laughed they laughed at
the idea
that they would ever want to move here
that's what we have made of ourselves on
the world stage
Remember When Donald Trump was President
we heard so much handwringing and
fretting from the left about how we
won't be respected on the world stage
in other countries I don't care about
who the president is whether it's Donald
Trump or someone else
it's about the culture
okay they're not they're looking at our
politics they're looking at our culture
and these non-western countries are
seeing our culture and seeing a culture
that has that is just
caving in on itself that is eating
itself
and uh they're saying I just I'm not
interested in your moral lectures can
you blame them I can't I just can't
all right let's see what else do we got
here Camilla Harris was in the uh
Philippines and
you know it's been a little serious a
little dark let's let's uh let's lighten
the mood a little bit because Camille
Harris has some inspirational
words to offer the the folks in the
Philippines and also all across the
world let's listen
the way that I think about it is you
know like relay racing you know you race
and someone passes the Baton and then
right so that's what life is it's
basically a relay race
and so the people who are heroes
whichever gender they are
they ran their part of the race and then
they passed us a baton
and the question is what will we do with
the time we carry the Baton
which means there's no time to get tired
come on
right you're gonna pass that baton at
some point
but right now you're carrying it
and the question is what are you doing
with it
hmm inspirational stuff from Camilla
Harris as as always she's got that
confident look on her face she believes
she's nailing it she's got something
really profound to say these faux
profundities to offer
about uh passing the it's the it's the
the relay race of life
you know she thought about she you know
she'd been working on that for a long
time she felt really proud of that
and in in you know to her credit it is
basically coherence I'll give her that
but even that it's like this is the
position they're on in the Democrat
Party
and on the left this is the position
they're in or even some even just some
like cliche platitude like that the
relay race of Life carry the Baton they
can't even say that stuff anymore
because that's not what they actually do
right they're not taking the Baton from
past Generations from our ancestors and
just running forward
no they they take the Baton and then
they they stand there on the track and
look at it and say this is disgusting I
don't want to what are we doing here
this is I don't want to take a baton
from you
you bigots get away from me they won't
even take the Baton
they they're standing on the track like
getting into an argument with the guy
who's trying to pass the Baton to them
here
we've this is the country we've built
for you so far there's still a lot of
work to do but but just keep going
no I know better than you
so they actually will not take the Baton
from past Generations they're too busy
you know
tearing down the statues
they the the guy tries to hand the Baton
they kneecap him
leave him there on the track
that's what the left does
all right I've had this for a couple of
days I wanted to mention this is from
Washington Post it says federal agents
and prosecutors have come to believe
former president Donald Trump's motive
for allegedly taking and keeping
classified documents was largely his ego
and a desire to hold on to the materials
as trophies or mementos according to
people familiar with the matter
as part of the organization Federal
authorities reviewed the classified
documents that were recovered from
Trump's Mar-A-Lago home and his private
club looking to see if the types of
information contained and then pointed
to any kind of pattern or similarity
according to the people who spoke on
condition of anonymity to discuss the
ongoing investigation
the review has not found any apparent
business advantages to the types of
classified information Trump's
possession these people said
and then it uh continues with more
details but this is just any any person
with a brain and who is able to assess
stories involving Donald Trump honestly
and this is a that's a that's a small
minority of people who are capable to do
that capable of doing that
but anyone in that category such as
myself already knew this like the idea
that Donald Trump took classified
documents to what sell them to the
Russians or to engage in Espionage that
this was some sort of high level
crime that he had cooked up
obviously not that was always obviously
the case
it's it's Donald Trump why do you keep
the documents because he felt like
keeping them you just want you just
wanted to have them he didn't really
think it mattered if he kept him or not
that's it that's that's why I took them
that's why he had them
uh that's all there is to it but it
shows that that you know for for the
media this is a revelation
this is months after the fact they're
saying well maybe maybe he wasn't trying
to sell it to Putin
maybe it's just like he just thought it
was a Memento he could keep
which is which is which is I mean love
them or hate him right it's like that's
a very Donald Trump thing he says I want
to keep these documents
I just like to have them
uh
that was always going to be the case but
but it shows how Trump's enemies they
still even now all these years later
after he's already been in the White
House they still don't understand him
which which is an advantage that he
continues to have over them that they
they do not understand it they don't
understand what makes them tick they
don't understand why he does the things
that he does
because they have totally bought into
this cartoon
villain narrative where Trump is just
that he's a comic book a villain
and everything he does it's with the
most nefarious and possible intentions
so whatever Trump is doing just imagine
the most evil reason why a person might
do that and it must be that reason
because he's literally Hitler they think
when most of the time it's just sort of
innocuous and this stuff with the with
the classified documents like many of us
were saying from the beginning it's just
innocuous it's nothing they were just
they were just boxes of paperwork you
didn't do anything with them
all right before we get to the uh
comment section I I feel as though I
just have to play this for you because I
I feel as though it's only fair if we
talk about this and acknowledge it
because I can be critical of adult men
speaking of comic books who take comic
book movies and video games too
seriously they get too invested in them
but Sports
can have the same infantilizing effect
if you don't moderate yourself so this
is kind of a cautionary tale and I'm a
sports fan
and so and this is something that I hear
anytime that I complain about uh adults
who play too many video games or too
obsessed with superheroes What I Hear in
response is what about you as a sports
fan how is that any more mature
and it's actually a good point
because if you get too invested in it if
you take it too seriously as an adult
then it it becomes quite absurd so again
a cautionary tale here's an exchange
that happened yesterday on a Fox Sports
show called Undisputed this is a an
exchange a show hosted by Shannon sharp
former NFL player and a this uh Sports
gas bag called Skip Bayless and here
they are arguing about what grade they
would give the quarterback Baker
Mayfield for his performance on Sunday
against the Baltimore Ravens that's the
argument so there's Baker Mayfield how
did he play what grade would you give
him arbitrarily after the fact and
this is what the argument sounded like
says he did last in qbr 17 points we're
talking about yesterday how do you look
yesterday no let me
let me because all you do is bring up
those 11 games all you do is go back to
talk about when he was a Ricky won seven
game I won't talk about what I want to
talk about because I got the floor Baker
Mayfield is dead lasting 2022 and qbr
57.8 he's 30 30.
you gonna let me talk
but you get on the floor for this clown
he's a bum he's trash and you know it
and every time you bring him up I won't
let the world know exactly what he is
okay you talk about Twitter if we come
out here and discuss topics that you
tweeted so don't give me about that
Twitter stuff you can talk about my
followers all you want but I got the
daddy right and you see how they do
America he's talking about my Twitter
followers that's what I know I got it
and I'm gonna continue to go he's 187.
tell me when it's my turn okay he feel
football
37 okay go ahead blah blah blah
that's that's sports that is that's
Sports media for you that's what you're
missing if you don't watch uh any sports
media these are grown adults like the uh
Shannon sharp is like in his 50s Skip
Bayless is in his 70s now he's in his
70s
you say that he's a bad quarterback I
think he's good I say he's a good
quarterback not bad
no he is bad I think he's good
that's that's the whole that's the whole
argument
grown adults and look there's it's I I
say
with sports the same thing I say with
any other record if you want to play
video games like there's nothing in
principle wrong with that
but if you find yourself
taking it really seriously okay if you
play a video game and and if you like
video games but then if someone else
thinks that video games are stupid and
that makes you
like that fills you with rage that
someone would criticize or not enjoy
your favorite Recreation
that's an indication that you take this
way too seriously because you don't
you're not an adult you're not you're
not an intellectual mental adult you're
still a child you're reacting the way a
child does when you take their popsicle
away and it's the same thing with with
sports nothing wrong with with watching
sports getting into it and all of that
but like is where you see these there's
alcohol involved obviously uh well there
might be alcohol involved here too but
there's alcohol involved in the stands
but you see these the the fans that
start like they commit felony assault
against each other you see someone with
it with with the other team's colored
Jersey
you want to kill him and you end up you
end up in prison for It Like It's that
kind of thing
you're you're not you're not you're not
a mental adult you're still a mental
child
so any kind of recreation because we're
a very unserious country with unserious
people any kind of recreation can become
a barrier to maturity if if you become
too invested in it
and you don't
supplement this Recreation with a with
actual adult interests like you know
things like like just reading books and
and that sort of thing
all right so there's the caution let's
get to the comment section
[Music]
Ivana says well I knew this day would
come sadly I don't agree with Matt on
something soccer is a normal great sport
like any other now what idiot people
have made it into is a different topic
has nothing to do with Communism I don't
know where he got this concept from but
okay it was funny well I got it from
science I don't know what to tell you
it's just a it is a matter it's been a
scientifically proven that everyone who
likes soccer is a communist and I don't
know what else to tell you it's just
that's that's where I got it from I got
it from
science and by the way congratulations
to the USA for their Victor I think they
won
didn't they yesterday
oh they tied
congratulations to the USA for their uh
great tie in the World Cup I don't know
what that means do they continue playing
to the next round or do they get thrown
into the sea I don't know what it is
hopefully the latter but uh because as I
already said they're not invited back to
the country with the whole rainbow Flags
done okay
excuse me butt says if Matt wasn't such
a ghoul he'd have the decency to feel
responsible for his verbal treatment of
lgbtq people
foreign
I'm just going to take that as a joke
because I assume that's what you meant
probably not but if I if I I should have
the decency
to
to uh adopt your Viewpoint of my own
words
if Matt had the decency he would he
would he would see his own opinions the
way that I see them it's indecent it's a
decent I say to disagree with me
good stuff James Dean says oh that
magical n-word when I say N word isn't
it like I'm saying the actual n-word
yeah this was a bit from I think it was
a bill Barr bit uh Bill not Bill Barr
Bill Burr rather I should say Bill
barmaid had some may have had some good
comedy boots but I think it was Bill
Burr pulling this out it's like that's
one of the absurdities of just the this
idea is like well you got to say the n
word you can't say the actual word
you're still saying it because you're
conveying you're communicating it to
somebody else if you're talking to
someone who who knows what the word is
then you are communicating the word
you're putting the word in their mind
you're communicating it you're referring
to it they know what you mean they say
oh it's that word and so you've still
communicated it the only difference is
that you haven't uttered the syllables
themselves but what is the significance
of the syllables what does it matter
what syllables they're just sounds so if
you avoid those particular you could say
the first
syllable right but you can't you can't
go beyond that
and yet you could still convey the word
it just doesn't it doesn't make any
sense
um
let's see
Jim R says Matt I have to admit I'm
uncomfortable with you suddenly becoming
an advocate for mail-in voting and early
voting we have to hold the line on
reforming these systems not allow
ourselves to get sucked into it
uh no I'm not an advocate for mail-in
voting or early voting I I hate both
systems as you know if you listen to the
show I'm actually in favor of
limiting the vote to same day in person
and even limiting the people who can
vote
in person like I want to limit I am an
unabashed restrictionist when it comes
to voting I think less people should be
voting and everyone who does vote with
few exceptions should be voting in
person on the same day so that's that's
my opinion but I'm also a realist
I'm in favor of dealing with and in
reality and and the reality is that
early voting and mail-in voting exist
they are happening and Democrats are
using them to win elections that's the
reality so we can either exploit the
system for our own ends or we can cross
our arms and stamp our feet and say I
don't want any part of it and then never
win another election again so those are
your options those are the only options
you can you can learn to exploit the
system or you can never win another
election only two options that's it
that's all that exists in reality now in
an Ideal World other options would exist
but we don't live in that world
and so especially when it comes to
elections and politics it's very
important that you operate in reality
Productions all day long in your fantasy
world that's great
I'm all I am president for life in my
fantasy world I am the Theocratic
fascist dictator of the entire world for
life in my but we're not in that fantasy
world
so we're in reality are you going to
operate within it or not are you going
to win the elections or not
I kind of think of it like this
and by the way if you want if you want
to if you want to fix the system and you
want to put some of these policies in
place that we're talking about you you
have to you have to have power first to
do it you can't do that from the outside
you can't change the law from the
outside you have to be in this you have
to be running the system in fact in
order to do that
which means in order to in order to do
that you have to you have to know how to
exploit the system you have to be able
to exploit the very system that you want
to change
the left has been very good about this
they've been very good at this for
decades that's how they got into the
position that they're in on the culture
they learned how to exploit the systems
that they then turned around and changed
I think of it like uh you know back a
few years ago the NFL speaking of sports
they changed the rules on kickoffs and
they moved the kickoff line up so that
the yard line so that they're kicking
from further up on the field which means
which which you know eliminates kick
returns for the other team because it
always goes It goes out back through the
end zone ends up with a Touchback and
the other team isn't able to return the
football and they did this so that they
could you know eliminate or negate
injuries on kickoff returns
now
I didn't like the rule change I think
the kickoff was the kickoff returns an
important part of the sport I don't like
that they took it out of the sport
but if I'm an NFL coach
and it's my turn to kick off I'm not
going to say well I don't like this rule
where we can move up farther to make
sure the other team can't return so I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna stick with
with the old kickoff line I'm gonna I'm
gonna kick the ball from further back
and give the other team a chance to
return it
just out of principle like you you've
changed I'm in a position as the kickoff
team where you've changed the rules that
would benefit me but I'm not going to
take advantage of those rules and I'm
going to put my team in a position to
lose on principle
um that doesn't make any sense and
that's to me it seems like what you're
advocating
that we just lose on principle
which of course is what conservatives
have been very good at doing for decades
but I'm for a change of pace
the new daily wire Plus store is live
and it's your One-Stop shop for
everything worth giving because the fact
is nobody wants a copy of white
fragility uh it's not on anyone's list
instead you got to go to dailywire.com
shop to get the things that you want
like Johnny The Walrus which has a
special deal it's a book that every kid
should read you can grab one of my
limited edition sweet baby album
t-shirts or uh for the truly committed
you know who they are pick up my Matt
Walsh Super Fan bundle shipping is free
on orders over 75 and with orders over a
hundred dollars you get a free leftist
tears tumbler so skip the Cyber awoke
this holiday and pick up gifts made
exclusively from truth go to
dailywire.com shop today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel a woman named Jessica
esquival PhD she describes herself as
not just a normal physicist but an
afro-latinx physicist which means that
her physics are far more inclusive and
Equitable than regular physics this is
the pitch she makes for herself and her
bio on her website where she describes
her professional Mission this way she
says as one of the few afro-latinx women
to graduate from Saint Mary's University
with a Bachelor of Science in electrical
engineering and applied physics and the
second to graduate from with a PhD in
physics from Syracuse University Dr
esquival understands traversing spaces
as the only and has a very personal
recognition of the importance of equity
diversity and inclusion
she traverses spaces as the only
I could not possibly come up with a
better way to summarize leftist thought
each individual thinks of themselves as
indeed the only the only what well just
the only
and of course the other Hallmark of
leftist thought especially when it comes
to academics is that these thoughts are
communicated in the worthiest clunkiest
least eloquent most awkward way possible
hence the phrase traversing spaces
Dr eskeval PhD doesn't simply walk
across a room she traverses a space
so if you're sitting across the table
from her at a dinner table uh she won't
ask you to pass the salt she'll beseech
you to convey the sodium chloride from
its current position to an approximate
location near to where she is physically
located in space
and you must heed her request
immediately given that she is after all
the only the one and only
anyway the one and only Dr Esky of all
PhD makes it into the cancellation today
because of her recent Ted Talk focused
on what she calls the queer Universe Dr
esquive all PhD has apparently noticed
that her far left comrades are having a
very difficult time using biological
science to formulate a coherent defense
of queer Theory and gender ideology so
she proposes that they abandoned that
Pursuit and instead seek validation and
Vindication in the field of quantum
physics
if gender ideology appears to make no
sense from a biological perspective
maybe she can make sense of it from a
physics perspective
and if she can't make sense of it at
least she hopes she can confuse people
enough to fool them into believing that
she made sense of it that seems to be
the goal of this talk titled the queer
Universe a Quantum explanation
so let's watch as much of it as we can
bear
queer
differing in some way from what is usual
or normal
Society we tend to think in absolutes
black or white
gay or straight male or female
but what if I were to tell you that the
universe is non-binary
that from cosmological State scales to
subatomic scales that the universe is
actually super queer
so it isn't such a crazy leap to assume
that everything inside our universe is
also clear
does that make you uncomfortable
or are you cautiously optimistic that
the universe may offer some comfort
my name is Dr Jessica scavelle I'm a
black Mexican queer neurodivergent woman
I'm also a particle physicist and today
leveraging my expertise on the
intricacies of the quantum realm we are
going to create a re-imagining of our
universe
now I have to say that if nothing else I
appreciate the visuals here a
blue-haired woke physicist blabbering
about the queer Universe to an empty
Stadium while a small group of people
walk around behind her completely
ignoring her she did say she's the only
after all in this case she's the only
one who attended her own lecture nobody
also no no notice also how she is
ostensibly preparing to give a talk
about science and yet while listing her
credentials her status as a physicist is
listed last after woman black Mexican
queer and neurodivergent
but if she has any legitimate scientific
insights to offer why does it matter
which alleged marginalized victim group
she belongs to what relevance does that
have
it's hard to imagine a legitimate
physicist beginning a speech by
announcing his sexual orientation
like I wasn't around to hear it myself
but I'm gonna I'm gonna guess that
Albert Einstein never opened a lecture
by saying my name is Albert Einstein I'm
a white cisgender heterosexual
neurodivergent german-born theoretical
physicist
that's because Einstein had brilliant
ideas and he was interested in letting
his ideas stand or fall on their own
merits Dr ask evolved PhD on the other
hand needs to prop up her ideas on the
crutch of victimhood
let's keep listening
everything around us
everything from the galaxies filled with
stars to the extraordinary depths of our
oceans filled with creatures beyond our
wildest dreams are made up of a
fundamental set of particles
these Teensy tiny particles live and
interact in a world unlike our own
in our macro world
we tend to think binary categorizations
and absolutes are the norm
but if we tunnel down into the smallest
spaces of our universe we enter a world
where weirdness and Chaos reign supreme
on the contrary Dr Esquivel PhD uh you
don't need to go down to the bottom of
the ocean or look under a microscope to
see a world where queerness and Chaos
reign supreme that's actually a good
description of our culture queerness and
Chaos Reigns Supreme and yet if she's
right that queerness Reigns Supreme at
the most basic level of reality if
indeed the universe is Queer as she says
that doesn't that mean that queerness
doesn't exist
if queer means abnormal and yet the
abnormal is normal then there is no
abnormal if the universe is queer then
nothing is queer
in order for a thing to be abnormal it
must as she says in the beginning differ
from what is normal
which means that there has to be a
normal for the abnormal thing to differ
from
so as always you know they want to have
their queer cake and eat it too she
wants to
proudly announce herself as queer taking
pride in her own abnormality and yet in
the next breath insists that she is not
abnormal at all because in fact
everything is queer everything is gay
everything is non-binary even the atoms
are gay
our entire universe is comprised of gay
particles she says
this is obviously totally inane
pseudoscientific New Age Babble but it's
also self-contradictory
ever since the days of Alfred Kinsey the
priests and priestesses of the sexual
Revolution have tried desperately to
convince us that their lifestyle choices
and sexual quirks are actually normal
and yet at the same time they also want
to cling to their victimhood card and
their identity as a supposedly oppressed
minority so they want to be a minority
and the majority at the same time
now I won't inflict much more of this on
you but let's hear how she wraps all
this up
all matter is a
conundrum that we Don
we don't even confounding still
even though all mattered in the universe
including atoms molecules humans plants
planets galaxies oceans
all of that only consists of five
percent of the visible matter that we
can see in our universe five percent
so the rest of it is dark energy and
dark matter and that's another
confounding topic for another talk
but all this to say that
it is an existential fact that we are
anomalies in our universe and the most
existential question at the heart of my
research is not if we are queer but why
we are queer
and I wonder
if we were to let the chaos of quantum
mechanics infiltrate our thinking if we
were to let go of those rigid processes
we have and become one with the queer
universe
I wonder maybe possibly
scientific discoveries would become
easier
you know this woman
spent like six years in college came out
with a doctorate and all of that just so
that she could tell us to become one
with the queer universe
I could not possibly think of a better
argument against student loan
forgiveness than that
now has she achieved her aim with this
lecture well
if her aim was to somehow prove that
non-binary and transgender identities
are valid by paddling on about queer
subatomic particles then no she has not
the fact that particles behave strangely
and unexpectedly does not legitimize the
illogical and biologically impossible
self-perceptions of human beings
subatomic particles can do lots of
things that entire human beings cannot
do they can pass through solid objects
for instance
Dr esque ball PhD is here taking a
common leftist tactic to extraordinary
and extraordinarily stupid lengths where
you know they often attempt to prove
that a person's self-identity and their
self-identity claim is legitimate by
drawing a comparison to a phenomenon
that occurs outside of the human species
so just last week we heard from someone
who attempted to prove that the sex
binary among human beings is false
by pointing to the fact that some
organisms like amoebas exist outside of
the sex binary like amoebas are asexual
they reproduce asexually
that's supposed to prove something about
that's supposed to validate amoebas
validate a claim that a man addresses
making about them no because who human
beings are not amoebas
and though human beings are comprised of
like zillions of sub atomic particles a
human being is not a subatomic particle
individually
but there's more important point to be
made here I think
which is to note
how small and diminished everything
becomes when it's filtered through queer
Theory or gender ideology whatever you
want to call it I mean physics is a
fascinating field I don't understand any
of it
but I do know that it can unlock and has
has unlocked some of the deepest
Mysteries of the universe the more you
understand physics the more you
understand the nature of the world of
the cosmos of reality and yet this woman
being an adherent to the LGBT religion
isn't interested in the secrets of the
universe the only Universe she cares
about is the universe of her own small
fragile ego
so rather than taking the tool of the
tool of physics and directing it out
into the world to understand and explore
she pointed back at herself
to obsess over and justify her own
personal and sexual preoccupations
the result is the nonsense you just
heard but worse than being merely
nonsense it's also boring and
uninteresting and dull and irrelevant
I suspect there's probably a fair amount
of nonsense offered by theoretical
physicists
but at least the nonsense is usually
fascinating and and directed towards the
pursuit of something greater something
Noble you know understanding the
universe
This Woman's nonsense on the other hand
is the result of trying to jam physics
into a space under the umbrella of queer
Theory
she's trying to subordinate it bring it
to heal
fit it into a hierarchy where lgbt's
self-interest stands at the very top
and this is what happens more and more
as institutions and scientific fields
are ideologically captured by the far
left they end up churning out a whole
bunch of bogus garbage and worse than
that they stop pursuing truth they stop
looking for it
because they're too busy looking in the
mirror
talking to themselves
and that is why Dr esquival PhD
is today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]